le procès de la dictature chilienne
celui de maurice papon ou encore celui
de klaus barbie d'ordinaire
inaccessibles au grand public les
extraits de huit procès historiques sont
exceptionnellement visible aux archives
départementales
ces procès
s'étendent sur des heures donc ce sont
quelques montages qui vont de 10 minutes
à 25 minutes et qui permettent
d'appréhender justement
les différents aspects d'un procès en
france il est interdit de filmer les
procès sauf exception considérée comme
historique certains peuvent être
conservés pour la mémoire en juillet
1985 la loi badinter autorise leur
enregistrement audiovisuel sous
conditions strictes nous avons à
l'intérieur de ce procès d'autres
personnes jugées et condamnées pour des
faits de collaboration donc c'est un
procès à ce sont des archives qui
couvrent
énormément d'aspects parmi les huit
procès exposé celui de paul touvier
accusé de crimes contre l'humanité la
sphère a été jugé par la cour d'assises
de versailles en 1994
la documentation est conservée aux
archives départementales à des yvelines
ce sont des plans fixes on ne peut pas
par exemple quand un témoin ou
un avocat s'exprime faire un contrechamp
pour analyser la réaction du public par
exemple ça se veut le plus objectif
possible l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir
une trace filmées de ce procès huit
mètres linéaires c'est l'ensemble de la
procédure concernant paul touvier un
fonds conséquents d'archivage
matérialisé par ses 67 boîte à leurs
côtés des pièces à conviction sous
scellés elles proviennent de documents
et d'objets personnels ça apporte une
matérialité voilà c'est à cette enquête
et à la procédure qui a été menée ce
sont des pièces qui vise à apporter un
éclairage sur la prétendue culpabilité
effectivement de la personne mise en
examen
l'exposition se termine le 22 avril 2022